my wife has a very low self-esteem
and i'm just trying to figure out a way
that i could help her
see her value more oh man that's an
awesome question
um that's an awesome question so walk me
through it give me an example of what
this looks like have you tried to help
in the past talk me through it
um yeah so she's always having negative
thoughts about herself
um she says things like
she doesn't think people care about her
because
um she's not worth it um
she says she's afraid that i'm gonna
find
someone else that's better than her i'm
gonna leave her
where does that co where does that come
from sean
um i don't know like did she get that
from her mom she get that from her dad
she get that from some high school
boyfriend
where does that negative self-talk come
from where did she learn that
probably from her parents um that
i think she has what you refer to as a
neglect trauma
okay um her dad was
very um and uh
controlling and had a bad temper
and her mom she couldn't go to her for
anything because she
her mom couldn't handle anything
emotionally
so so she got messaging both
affirmatively and neglectfully that she
didn't really matter
yeah she wasn't very important she was
in the way and
mom can't even deal with you dad's
annoyed by you that's angered by you
and so um your value
is little to none right
yeah okay yeah i think everything leads
back to that
okay so then sexy sean
shows up on the scene that was a
straight up rap lyric right there
that was some alliteration if i've seen
it sexy sean shows up on the scene
you all fall in love you get married and
then what
um so um
yeah so we've been married for well i've
known her for 15 years
okay we've been married for 12. and um
has this been an arc of your entire
relationship
yeah it seems like yeah from the very
beginning she
she kind of didn't understand why i
would
like her because she thought that she
was not um not good enough yeah
what do you tell her when she says
things like that
um i try to tell her
that it's not true that um she says
things like
that i don't love her but i try to tell
her how i
how i actually feel um
i try to sometimes i just try to
hold her or hug her and um
show her other kind of um like give her
gifts sometimes and
you know sometimes she feels okay
uh for moments she believes in for a
moment and then
um a few days later she goes back to the
to the negative thinking okay has she um
been in and out of therapy for 14 years
or 15 years
um no she hasn't really been in therapy
at all okay
okay so um there
my guess is this there's a lot here
i will give you a one particular
scenario that may or may not be
right but it may be not entirely
accurate but i think i'm pretty darn
close
okay you ready yeah
there were two people if it all goes
down
the apocalypse is upon us there are two
people
who are supposed to hold your hand and
put their hand on your face
and tell you that i love you and i am in
this with you till it's all over
and that's the mom and dad of a precious
little girl
yeah and her mom and dad did the
opposite
it all came down in whatever not really
apocalypse in their house but
in their imaginary house apocalypse it
all came down and one parent said i
can't even deal with you
and the other parent raised his voice
and or his hands
and said this is because of you
and imprinted on this young beautiful
little girl at a young age was you are
in the freaking way
by the two people who when it all when
all the smoke cleared
should still be standing by here they
let her know
the smoke's your fault and so
at an early age she took on an identity
of a burden
she took on identity of somebody who is
unlovable
and that's how she keeps controlling her
world
okay okay over time
this is how she keeps herself from
getting hurt this is how she controls
you
so instead of saying hey i really just
want to hug tonight
can we just have a night of hugging
instead of affirmatively asking for it
because she may have done that as a kid
and mom said i can't deal with you
so instead of doing that the way she
gets her hugs is by saying nobody loves
me
i don't even know why you love me why
don't you just leave you're going to
leave anyway
and then you come and hug her right so
she gets what she wants
but in the process she's drowning you
right
right so i'm going to say this
she's going to have to choose that she
wants a different identity
one that is not as we in the nerd world
we call it the one down position
where she maintains control of your over
your entire house
underneath the boat by saying she's just
controlling the boat from underneath it
by saying nobody loves me
and then everyone's got to stop with her
doing and respond to her right
and what she's going to have to decide
to do is she doesn't like being in the
water anymore
she wants to be on top of the boat she
wants to be on the land she wants to be
in a really nice home with the people
who love her
and that she's worth being loved and she
is gonna her voice is gonna matter
and she's gonna be able to say hey sean
tonight's hug night
and i don't want you to do anything but
focus on me because i'm awesome
and you're gonna be like sweet i'm sexy
sean
on the scene and you're gonna show up
right
so it's twofold number one she's gonna
have to decide that
after a lifetime of running
sometimes often folks need professional
help there
to help them make that transition from
you are worthless
to your parents sucked and you are
of value here's a guy who has dedicated
his life to you
and you are going to learn new ways of
communicating to one another
does that make sense yeah so sean
what i want you to do is i want you to
lead the way
and i want you to let her know that you
are going to
um start seeing a counselor there in
boise idaho
and i want you to let her know that you
love her so much you're going to learn
you're going to invest in learning some
new skills some new ways that you can
teach her
how valuable and how much you love her
and you want to grow
as a guy who is in love with with a
young lady
and i want you to encourage her to go
with you she probably won't or she may
say something like oh because you think
i'm screwed up and broken too
and your answer to that will be no no i
want
you to see the same beautiful
wonderful lovely young lady that i see
and i'm right because you are beautiful
and
lovely and wonderful and you don't see
it
and so i want i would love for you to go
with me and we're going to learn some
new skills
so that you can see her too and i can
learn new skills on how to love her even
deeper and better than i already do
unfortunately you're not gonna be able
to force her to do this
and sometimes your action is gonna even
actually make it worse
oh you're going to therapy that must
mean that like fill in the blank
at the end of the day she's gonna have
to decide
that she's worth being well she's gonna
have to decide that she is worth being
loved
and man something about being truly
connected with somebody else
in a loving relationship starts a
healing process
then you can start practicing new skills
then you can start approaching the world
head high face first instead of butt
first right with negativity negativity
you don't love me you don't want me
everything's bad everything's gray and
it starts with that decision
you can't control that you can't control
you brother
so i want to applaud you for being a
husband who wants to help
the way you can help right now is
leading by example the way you can help
right now
is by inviting her not forcing
manipulating or anything you can invite
her in
and then you start the healing process
for yourself because here's the other
part
you've been told for 14 years or 13
years that the way you love isn't enough
and so whether you know it or not sean
you've got trauma too brother
and so i want you to go and start
getting well too
i want you to start your own healing
journey and again invite her invite her
invite her
we need more guys like you sean i
appreciate you man